jetzt die debatte im deutschen bundestag
in form einer aktuellen stunde katharina
kühn bringt sie auf den stand und kennt
die hintergründe
die eine krise ja und hier im deutschen
bundestag hat die aktuelle stunde auf
verlangen der unionsfraktion schon
angefangen titel ist hunger vermeiden
mehr lebensmittel produzieren statt
ackerflächen stilllegen es geht um die
europäische gemeinsame agrarpolitik in
der eigentlich die landwirte
aufgefordert werden ab 2023 mindestens
vier prozent der ackerfläche
stillzulegen und die union ich kürze das
nun ein bisschen zusammen möchte das
noch einmal diskutieren eben aufgrund
der vorher zu sehenden
lebensmittelknappheit aufgrund des
krieges wir hören jetzt rein was steffen
bilger der erste redner in dieser
debatte zu dieser aktuellen stunde sagt
weltweit rund 200 millionen menschen
unter hunger und krieg in der ukraine
wirkt wie ein brandbeschleuniger
ein weiter so als ob nichts wäre bis
zynisch ist unethisch ist in meinen
augen ausgeschlossen meint er
ich glaube dass das anstehende g 7
treffen spannende für manche beteiligte
auch schmerzhafte erkenntnis ans licht
bringen wird die bisherige g7 agenda von
schmerz zu mir passt nicht mehr in die
zeit des ukraine kriegs und sich
weltweit verschärfenden
versorgungsengpässe und die partei
agenda der grünen der
landwirtschaftspolitik ist nicht
mehrheitsfähig nicht in europa und auch
nicht im kreise der g 7 jetzt meine
damen herren ist nicht die zeit für halb
rio so fische betrachtung von
klimaschutz ernährungssicherung und
frieden als neuem dreiklang wie sie der
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister gerne
anstellt mir drängt sich der verdacht
auf da will einer ein ohnehin schon
gewaltiges problem mit möglichst vielen
anderen vor ketten um vielleicht vom
eigenen nichtstun abzulenken und der
einsicht aus dem weg zu gehen dass der
eigene kurs eben korrigiert werden muss
genau hierfür wünsche ich den
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister den
nötigen mut nur wenn er den hat und
jetzt endlich die ernährungssicherung in
den mittelpunkt seines handelns zurück
dann kann er auch die dinge
aufgeschrieben ebene glaubwürdig
vorantreiben deshalb herr minister
lassen sie die grüne partei jährigen
kommen sie endlich in den krisenmodus
tun sie das was jetzt in dieser zeit
geboten ist damit die von der
bundesregierung ausgerufene zeitenwende
in ihrem zuständigkeitsbereich nicht nur
eine leere worthülse ist
soweit steffen bilger aus der
unionsfraktion der hier die aktuelle
stunde gewonnen hat in der sich die
union über die gemeinsame agrarpolitik
der eu aus lassen möchte auf ihn folgt
nun franziska kersten aus der spd
fraktion
sehr geehrte damen und herren uns allen
ist der ernst der lage bewusst der
furchtbare krieg in der ukraine führt
tut not und leid bei der bevölkerung
dies höre ich übrigens momentan auch von
einer praktikantin oder stipendiatin die
bei mir arbeiten und deren familie
wirklich im kriegsgebiet lebt der
konflikt hat aber auch auswirkungen auf
die globale versorgung mit
nahrungsmitteln das kann zu neuen
fluchtbewegungen aufführen wie können
wir mit unserer agrarpolitik darauf
reagieren soll die stilllegung der vier
prozent ackerflächen von 20 23
ausgesetzt werden sollen wir die reform
der gemeinsamen agrarpolitik verschieden
um ein jahr wie von der cdu gewünscht
oder sollen das ganz sein lassen und
einfach so viel produzieren wie
irgendwie möglich ist ich sage ihnen
ganz ehrlich dass wer so argumentiert
denkt zu kurz ihre fragen die gestorben
der gemeinsamen agrarpolitik haben wir
nicht aus hygienischer
der ist ja nicht hier als gut also die
gemeinsame reform der gemeinsamen
agrarpolitik
haben wir noch nicht aus ideologischer
verblendung hervor angeschoben fakt ist
doch dass hitzeperioden und
wetterkapriolen zu nehmen die
niederschlagsmengen in meinem wahlkreis
also in der börde und im jerichower land
liegen aktuell wieder deutlich unter dem
langjährigen
mittel wir haben in sachsen anhalt ein
echtes problem mit wasserknappheit in
der landwirtschaft der heutige
abendliche landwirtschaftsminister sven
schultze wird das sicherlich bestätigen
können unsere landwirtschaft muss sich
an den klimawandel anpassen wir brauchen
keine einfachen lösung sondern
handlungen mit augenmaß wir brauchen
eine kurzfristige intensivierung nicht
sondern wir brauchen residente
ökosysteme
und das
die universität hier kommt stellung
stilllegungsflächen ins spiel sie
erfüllen wichtige funktionen für den
wasserhaushalt sowie als rückzugsraum
für flora und frauen nahmen die vier
prozent die ab 20 23 stillgelegt werden
sollen sind schon ein extrem
heruntergeschraubt kompromiss darauf
können wir nicht auch noch verzichten
wir können biodiversität nicht einfach
an- und abschalten an und anschalten das
ist eigentlich nicht möglich das müsste
ihnen bewusst sein auf einmal
verschwunden ist bleibt auf dauer
verschwunden
übrigens hat sich auch der gerade
wiedergewählte ministerpräsident von
schleswig-holstein daniel günther im
november 21 auf dem naturschutz tag der
biodiversität
verschrieben vielleicht haben sie das
nicht mitbekommt dass es so war aber er
hat das so geredet das ist wichtig wäre
und dass wir dann gut wenn das die cdu
fraktion auch wahrnimmt
die vorteile der nutzung von
brachflächen verhalten sich das
proportional zu den ökologischen kosten
im übrigen sind die meisten brauchen
eben nicht ertragsreiche sondern grenz
standorte für die futter nutzung sind
sie frei gegeben das ist aber für den
browser ein großer mehraufwand inklusive
düngung und pflanzenschutz notwendig und
wir wissen angesagt an die sich der
momentanen bürgerpreis ist das
illusorisch und brotgetreide werden auf
den meisten flächen auch nicht
produziert werden können auch die
absolute größe der flächen in höhe von
170000 hektar lässt eine wirksame
bekämpfung des welthungers unrealistisch
erscheinen der frucht wechsel ist eine
entscheidende maßnahmen zur förderung
der bodenfruchtbarkeit und der
pflanzengesundheit auch hier müssen wir
mit augenmaß vorgehen auf guten
standorten leidet die brot bodenqualität
nicht wenn der weizen zweimal
hintereinander angebaut wird deshalb
unterstützen wir als fraktion sehr den
vorschlag von cem özdemir da diesen
pflicht zum frucht 6er erstmal
auszuheben
auf diesem weg kann man einen
schnelleren beitrag zur weltweiten
weizenproduktion leisten das bringt auch
deutlich mehr als brachen zu nutzen auch
beim thema gewässerrandstreifen kann
nachgesteuert werden hier müssen wir uns
die betroffenen wasserläufe genauer
ansehen und nach deren bedeutung auch
unterscheiden und wir müssen auch die
öko regelung ab 20 23 noch einmal
überdenken nur wenn zusätzliche
maßnahmen der landleute für unser
ökosystem auch angemessen honoriert
werden kann die neue gab funktionieren
es ist übrigens bezeichnet das im
bundeslandwirtschaftsministerium unter
julia klöckner damals genau das
verhindert wurde das war eben nicht
attraktiv für die landwirte
längerfristig würde eine umstellung zu
mehr klassen basierte ernährung zu einem
verminderten druck auf die globalen
getreidemärkte ausführen für mich sind
auch eine reduktion des fleischkonsums
der ces stände der lebensmittelabfälle
und der nutzung von bioethanol in europa
für entscheidende faktoren so lassen
sich der nachfragedruck auf die globalen
getreide und finanz futtermittel märkte
reduzieren und die preissteigerung an
dem was uns jetzt nicht hilft ist ganz
klar
kurzfristiges produziert um jeden preis
ohne die ökologischen folgen zu sehen
wir müssen jetzt mit augenmaß handeln
und ich bitte alle das mit zu verfolgen
und das würden uns zukünftige
generationen danken
jahre lang kam die eu mitgliedstaaten
über eine reform der gemeinsamen
agrarpolitik
diskutiert nun soll sie 2023 kommen und
da sollen dann die förderungen mehr an
umweltstandards geknüpft sei dazu
diskutiert auch der bundestag und jetzt
stefan tutschka für die afg er ist
agrarpolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion
die kolleginnen und kollegen dort zum
gruße endlich mit der gäste hier im
hohen haus wegen dem
völkerrechtswidrigen angriff lusthaus
auf die ukraine von mehr als ein viertel
der weltweit der weltweiten
weizenexporte ersatzlos weg ja das ist
katastrophal und mit trifft es trifft
die ärmsten der armen die armen länder
in afrika und im nahen osten die er
teilweise bis zu 90 prozent von weizen
antworten aus genannten ländern abhängig
sind internationale organisationen
wollen uns davor dass die zahl der
hungernden menschen von ort minimum um
acht bis maximal 45 millionen steigen
wird für uns als alternative für
deutschland steht ganz klar fest dass
wir angesichts dieser schrecklichen
zahlen eine humanitäre verpflichtung und
verantwortung haben und dass wir helfen
müssen
theoretisch wäre allein in deutschland
eine zusätzliche
getreideproduktion von bis zu zwei
millionen tonnen möglich aber deutscher
und nach ordentlicher minister hätte mir
hat sich ja leider als einziges land in
der eu gegen die freigabe von
stillgelegen landwirtschaftlichen
flächen für den ordnungsmittel am bau
entschieden anders ausgedrückt
deutschland verzichtet auf 45 milliarden
brötchen von denen etwa 20 millionen
menschen täglich ernährt werden hätten
können sie hält sie mir sind schuld für
die bilder der hungernden kinder aus
afrika
aber wir wollen wir daran wurden länger
arbeiten denn viel wichtiger ist ja der
blick auf den elefanten im raum den bis
dato leider nur corner angesprochen hat
oder sich vielleicht gar nicht
ansprechen traut das ist die inflation
da seit über einem halben jahr also
lange vor dem ukrainer krieg steigt die
inflationsrate in deutschland dramatisch
an die extreme kostenexplosion bei
energie und düngemittel sind seit
monaten massiv existenzbedrohend für
heimische landwirtschaft und gefährden
dadurch mittelfristig auch die
versorgungssicherheit mit lebensmittel
bei uns im land der neue streich vom
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister sind jetzt
aber dann sowas dass die
landwirtschaftlichen betriebe jetzt
einfach neue kredite aufnehmen sollten
und sich weiter verschulden sollten
damit sie sich den dünger und den
agrardiesel leisten können ja das ist ja
absurd also welcher noch halbwegs normal
denkende mensch würde ein kredit
aufnehmen damit dass eine tankfüllung
kaufen kann damit denn der arbeit fahren
kommt damit dass sie wieder randvoll und
kaufen kann das ist doch ein blödsinn
kam zu übertreiben und das schadet nur
unseren bauern und alle
mittelständischen hier in diesem land
aber was interessiert es uns eine e mail
an großen audi oder mercedes bau stehen
und wird natürlich mit ihren chauffeur
durch die gegend kutschiert meine damen
und herren
[Applaus]
aber fast nur kurz zusammen wir haben
eine dramatische
lebensmittel verknappung und steuern auf
einen enormen weltweiten hungers nutzen
die heimische landwirtschaft kann sich
kaum noch die produktion leisten und
zehntausende betriebe stehen vor dem
unwiederbringlichen aus der form einer
anhörung bei der freude unter wasser was
weg ist ist weg damit sind aber der
anbau und die ernte nicht nur in diesem
jahr sondern auch in den nächsten jahren
sehr gefährdet die lebensmittelpreise in
deutschland sind für breite teile des
volkes bereits unbezahlbar tendenz
steigend die tafeln die linken haben
eingeladen wird die taufen und sorgen
wegen steigender armut alarm und sind
extrem überlastet und was macht der
grünen landwirtschaftsminister in dieser
katastrophalen situation er kümmert sich
um hühner warnwesten und will natürlich
an den hang freigeben wollte lópez
bekifft besser auszuhalten ist meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren aber
dieser skandal thema vielleicht aus dem
taka tuka land kennt aber nicht aus
deutschland und liebe union sie müssen
doch jetzt übrigens jedoch in ihrem
agrarminister den glöckner und
werbevideos mit nestlé gedreht der
özdemir kümmert sich um den westen für
für hühner also alles übertrieben sorgen
sie endlich für spürbare entlastung
unserer bäuerlichen familienbetriebe und
für bezahlbare energie und
lebensmittelpreise die wir schon seit
monaten fordern und übrigens liebe cdu
csu schon vor recht gefordert haben wir
haben doch nur von uns abgeschrieben ob
ihr wollt oder recht haben wir alle
zustimmen aber ist ja schön wenn sie gut
die anträge von uns übernehmen dann
können wir denen zustimmen das
wichtigste ist dass geholfen wird und
wenn sie glücklich sind dann mit einer
kommenden tage sagt von ihnen danke
schön meine damen und herren
stefan potyka hat hier den
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister stark
angegriffen er sei verantwortlich für
die hungernden kinder in afrika er kann
jetzt darauf reagieren
ist der nächste in der regel ist
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen
meine herren zurzeit hungern weltweit
über 800 millionen menschen in dieser
ohnehin schon dramatische situation
setzt putin hunger als waffe ein er
klaut getreide er stiehlt er zerstört
recke und metrische besonders durch die
steigenden lebensmittel- und
energiepreise sind millionen von
menschen weltweit zusätzlich von hunger
bedroht wir sehen dramatische bilder aus
indien wo der weizen sprichwörtlich auf
dem feld verbrennt ostafrika leitet und
eine langanhaltende dürreperiode der
hunger ist schon vor dem krieg dort groß
wo die klimakrise bereits voll zuschlägt
genau über diese sich gegenseitig
verstärkenden krisen werde ich in den
kommenden tagen mit den
agrarministerinnen agrarministern der g
7 in stuttgart sprechen vor ort anwesend
wird auch mein ukrainischer kollege soll
ski seien auch im namen dieses
parlaments werde ich ihm meine und
unsere solidarität und anteilnahme
ausdrücken
nach der letzten rede würde ich
vielleicht einschränkend hinzufügen im
namen der demokratischen mehrheit des
hauses nicht des rechten randes der
bisher gleich da könnte ich sie ja
gleich von herrn putin größten ich
glaube das kann man eben nicht zumuten
wir werden mit ihnen darüber rat beraten
wäre sein land und den agrarsektor
unterstützen können wir werden natürlich
auch beraten wie wir die globalen folgen
dieses völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg für die welternährung
begrenzen es geht jetzt um kurzfristige
maßnahmen damit wir den akuten hunger
bekämpfen können da wäre diese aktuelle
stunde eigentlich eine großartige
gelegenheit um die ernsthafte debatte zu
führen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
von tokio
stattdessen stattdessen wollen sie
tatsächlich über grenz ertrags flächen
über hecken überfällt gehört zu
diskutieren und diese die wie sie wissen
sehr wertvoll sind für artenschutz
nutzinsekten bestäubern diese
artenvielfalt flächen dient dazu unsere
ernährung auch morgen noch zu sichern
auf diese
auf diese artenvielfalt fläche wollen
sie teuren dünger schicken der dann
übrigens woanders in der welt fehlt um
das recht auf nahrung der menschen vor
ort zu stärken aber spannend ist ja
spannend ist das worüber sie nicht reden
da sollte man eigentlich aufmerksam zu
führen dass 60 prozent des getreides von
kühen schweinen und hühnern gefressen
wird darüber wollen sie nicht reden die
cdu
bei cdu/csu sind logik einerseits und
ideologie andererseits zwei seiten
derselben medaille
nur so kann man ihre zukunft vergessene
agrarpolitik verstehen
wir
wir unterstützen wir unterstützen unsere
landwirtschaft mit zielgerichteten
hilfsmaßnahmen wir erhöhen die 60
millionen euro aus der eu krisen reserve
um die maximal möglichen 120 millionen
euro auf 180 millionen dafür bin ich dem
finanzminister sehr dankbar und diese
wollen wir schnell und effizient an die
bäuerinnen und bauern bringen wir werden
die aktuell besonders von steigenden
energiepreisen betroffenen
gartenbaubetriebe obst und weinbau und
die tierhaltungsbetriebe entlasten bei
der frage nach tank und teller sage ich
teller zuerst
wir müssen
wir müssen die flächenkonkurrenz zu
lasten der lebensmittelerzeugung endlich
auflösen deshalb unterstütze ich auch
den vorschlag des federführenden
bundesumweltministeriums und von meiner
kollegin steffi lemke ausdrücklich die
beimischungsquoten für agrosprit
abzusenken meine damen meine herren wir
schauen uns jeden einzelnen punkt an wie
drehen jedes korn um und wägen die
kosten gegen die nutzen ich habe deshalb
die nutzung des aufwuchses von
brachflächen und der zwischenfrüchte
ökologischen vorrangflächen für
zusätzliche futter kapazitäten
ermöglichen ermöglicht es waren
pragmatischen kompromiss
denn diese artenvielfalt flächen müssen
auch weiter vor einem intensiven einsatz
von düngern und pestiziden geschützt
werden gleichzeitig setze ich mich in
brüssel dafür ein dass die neue regelung
zum fruchtwechsel verschoben wird damit
unsere bauern mehr weizen produzieren
können damit kann bei dieser
damit kann bei dieser herbstaussaat
weizen auf weizen angebaut werden sagen
allerdings auch das muss man
ehrlicherweise sagen dafür zahlen umwelt
und böden ein preis aber ich finde
dieser kompromiss steht in einem
vertretbaren verhältnis zur
notwendigkeit meine damen meine herren
die bundesregierung unterstützt das
world food programm und die fau mit 370
millionen euro sie setzt 430 millionen
euro für die globale ernährungssicherung
1 in der task-force ernährungssicherheit
arbeiten wir mit dem auswärtigen amt und
dem bmz gemeinsam an maßnahmen und
kurzfristig humanitäre hilfe in die von
hunger bedrohten länder dieser welt zu
bringen um ihnen zu helfen die erzeugung
vor ort zu stärken denn die weltweite
ernährung sie wird vor allem von
kleinbäuerinnen und kleinbauern vor ort
geleistet dort müssen wir unterstützen
dort liegt ein gewaltiges potenzial um
die ernährung weltweit zu sichern wir
handeln konkret sie hingegen haben schon
ab dem ersten tag des russischen
angriffskriegs auf die ukraine
sprechzettel wieder ausgepackt dabei
dabei ist ihre bilanz
ich wollte ja nicht darüber reden weil
der blick nach vorne eigentlich
weiterführen würde aber nach der rede
muss man es gerade zu dabei ist ihre
bilanz nach 16 jahren schwarz geführt im
agrarministerium wie sie sicherlich
selber einräumen würden doch sehr
verheerend vertrags
vertragsverletzungsverfahren nicht
gelöst der um bode tierhaltung
vertrödelt höfesterben nicht gestoppt
ich frag mich eigentlich wenn ich ihn so
zu höherer woher nehmen sie das
selbstbewusstsein angesichts dieser
desaströsen bilanz die meine ich rede um
jede maßnahme und ein höhe hin so denkt
wenig leisten viel reden wir machen es
jetzt umgekehrt die landwirtin landwirt
in diesem land verdient besseres vor
allem verdienen die ernsthaftigkeit
wir müssen
wir müssen die krisen mehrere krisen
gleichzeitig lösen ohne die eine gegen
die andere auszuspielen sie dadurch zu
verschärfen deshalb wünsche ich mir hier
ernsthafte debatte die den problemen der
menschen gerecht wird hier als auch
weltweit heute als auch morgen
herzlichen dank
der
bundesminister cem özdemir hier in
dieser aktuellen stunde ja wie kann die
ernährungssicherheit garantiert werden
und gleichzeitig die natur geschützt
werden darüber diskutieren die
abgeordneten und die nächste rednerin
ist in altendorf sprecherin für
landwirtschaft ländliche räume und
tierschutz der linksfraktion liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
ihre forderungen im titel der aktuellen
stunde haben wir in den letzten wochen
nicht selten vernommen vom bauernverband
den freien bauern und anderen sie
möchten eine erhöhung der
lebensmittelproduktion verbinden diesen
wunsch mit der extensiven nutzung
landwirtschaftlicher nutzflächen und
emotionalen dies damit hunger vermeiden
zu wollen
ziel ist behaarung im status quo weder
vermeidet man mit diesen dreh
irgendwelche versorgungsengpässe noch
entspricht dieses ansinnen den
grundsätzen einer nachhaltigen
landwirtschaft im gegenteil ganz
schamlos nutzt die agrarlobby den krieg
in ost für ihre interessen diese möchte
die produktion intensivieren den
ökolandbau schwächen nutzflächen weiter
ausdehnen und eine naturverträgliche
landwirtschaft eigentlich nicht mehr
stattfinden lassen man kann es oft nicht
oft genug wiederholen der krieg in der
ukraine hat die europäischen und
weltweiten
probleme der lebensmittelversorgung
nicht unvermittelt erzeugt
versorgungsschwierigkeiten in der
ernährung haben wir seit langem vor
augen stichwort welthungerhilfe sonst
würde es die nicht geben erst jetzt wo
europa betroffen ist fangen viele an
sich sorgen zu machen aber was ist mit
dem dauerkrieg in jemen und in syrien
was ist mit der existentiellen jüngere
krise in afrika was ist mit der
hitzewelle in indien was ist mit dem
abtragen landwirtschaftliche
anbaugebiete in küstenregionen in denen
der anstieg des meeresspiegels die
lebensgrundlage bedroht
meine damen und herren sorgen machen
müssen wir uns durchaus und zwar große
und das schon seit längerer zeit aber
nicht wegen der stilllegung der
ackerflächen in der europäischen region
die ursachen liegen in der art des
wirtschaftens der spekulation ungleicher
ressourcenverteilung und falsche
subventionspolitik
die linke hat immer gefordert dass die
weitgehende sicherung der ernährung aus
eigener produktion ein wesentliches ziel
soziale und ökologisch gerechte
landwirtschaftspolitik sein muss und
nicht auf kosten der ärmeren länder der
welt und nicht zu lasten der ökologie
und ebenso wenig auf dem rücken der
bevölkerungsgruppen mit geringen
einkommen
verwerflich die profitorientierte
produktion landwirtschaftlicher güter
ihre zwillingsschwester heißt
spekulation mit nahrungsmitteln eine
börsennotierte elende plus macherey mit
der ernährung zu lasten der verbraucher
der internationale experten rat für
nachhaltige ernährung berichtete im mai
22 dass sich die lebensmittelpreise nun
schon zum dritten mal in den letzten 15
jahren im schatten von ökonomischen und
politischen krisen deutlich verteuert
haben menschen in deutschland und in der
welt leiden unter hohen
lebensmittelpreisen und gleichzeitig
haben deutsche düngemittelhersteller
ihren gewinn in den ersten drei monaten
22 vervierfacht
die gründe dafür liegen in der
wirtschaftlichen abhängigkeit von großen
unternehmen
und nicht zuletzt in der spekulation von
nahrungsmitteln teuerungsraten bei
getreide von 54 prozent sind derzeit zu
verzeichnen und selbst wenn man den
anteil des krieges in osteuropa
herausrechnen würde es bleibt eine
erhebliche spekulations größe übrig die
seit der finanzkrise 2008 in mehreren
wellen ursächlich ist für die
preisanstiege den begegnet man nicht mit
produktionssteigerungen und zusätzlichen
flächen ausbeutung sondern mit der
beseitigung der motive für die
spekulation
und ein weiterer aspekt kommt hinzu der
spiegel zitierte april 22 aus einer
studie der umweltorganisation transport
und transport & environment in europa
werden täglich 10.000 tonnen weizen zu
ethanol verarbeitet
umgerechnet 15 millionen brote um bei
dem beispiel mit den nahrungsmitteln zu
bleiben meine damen und herren wir uns
angesetzt werden alles andere wäre
verantwortungslos
derzeit hungern hunderte millionen
menschen weltweit aber nur 50 prozent
der weltweiten getreideernte dienen der
menschlichen ernährung die grundfrage
stelle statt tank ist hier zu stellen
und sie muss dann auch land
wirtschaftlich und ökologisch vernünftig
beantwortet werden es geht also
keineswegs darum die ökonomisch
gesättigten und monopol artig
aufgeteilten lebensmittelmärkte weiter
mit zusätzlichen und oft auch unnötigen
waren zu überschwemmen heute früh haben
wir im agrarausschuss noch doch ganz
deutlich gesagt es gibt keinen mengen
sondern ein verteilungsproblem und ein
bezahlung problem es muss dafür gesorgt
werden dass alle menschen ausreichend
gesunde lebensmittel sich auch leisten
können es darf kein weiter so geben das
versorgungs verteilungs und überlebens
dilemma darf nicht noch manifestiert
werden meine damen und herren die linke
streitet dafür eine zeitgemäße
ressourcenschonende agrar und
ernährungspolitik zu entwickeln es geht
nur im zusammenspiel mit sozialer
gerechtigkeit nachhaltigkeit und
versorgungssicherheit und zwar mit dem
von uns linken vorgeschlagenen sozial
ökologischen umbau der gesellschaft
vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp-fraktion hat nun die
kollegin carina konrad das buch
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir diskutieren
jetzt nachmittag über ein ernstes thema
seit 77 tagen kämpfen die menschen in
der ukraine für die freiheit seit 770
tagen ist die welt eine andere
und es wird nicht nur ein land
angegriffen das demokratisch das
freiheitlich leben wollte mit der
ukraine hat russland die kornkammer
europas angegriffen und die folgen auf
diese reaktion und die reaktionen darauf
die sind weltweit dramatisch die preise
für agrarrohstoffe die haben
rekordniveau erreicht das merken wir bei
uns an der kasse im supermarkt die
ärmsten und die armen die spüren dass
direkt in ihren mägen in form von hunger
russland schottet seine märkte zudem ab
und verschärft die situation dadurch und
was wir alles schon vor dem krieg
gemerkt haben ist doch dass die
klimaveränderungen agrarproduktion
verändern das spüren wir im moment auch
aktuell denn die prognosen der
erntemengen weltweit werden im moment
wöchentlich nach unten korrigiert weil
in vielen regionen der welt dürre
herrscht auch bei uns ist es sehr
trocken hier in deutschland das wird in
der allgemeinen debatte immer gerne
übergangen deshalb ist es richtig wenn
sie sagen liebe union sie beantragen
diese aktuelle stunde aus einem guten
grund sie wollen nicht klimaschutz und
ernährungssicherheit klimaschutz und
produktivität gegeneinander ausspielen
aber genau das tun sie doch genau das
tun sie doch an der stelle liebe
kollegen sieht unklar hier in dieser
aktuellen stunde heute die folgen einer
politik die sie in den letzten 16 jahren
selbst zu beantworten hatten
und wir haben sie vergessen wer die
landwirtschaftsministerien gestellt hat
in den letzten jahren nicht kann ihnen
sagen und davon bin ich fest überzeugt
davon ist meine fraktion fest überzeugt
wir brauchen einen paradigmenwechsel in
der agrarpolitik
aber die letzte bundesregierung hat uns
ein schweres erbe hinterlassen mit der
gab damit belohnt wird still legt da
wird belohnt wer nichts tut da wird
belohnt wer extensiviert der wird auf
kosten des steuerzahlers
subventions optimierung für die betriebe
geradezu angereist und das ist doch
nicht die richtige politik glauben sie
wirklich dass diese politik den
aktuellen herausforderungen angemessen
ist ich glaube das nicht ich habe
landwirtschaft gelernt ich habe
landwirtschaft studiert ich
bewirtschafte bis heute ein betrieb mit
meiner familie ich kann ihnen sagen wo
welchen herausforderungen wir stehen wir
dürfen nachhaltigkeit viele nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen deshalb kann
ich ihnen sagen die wir freie demokraten
unterstützen den landwirtschaftsminister
gerade in der aktuellen schwierigen
situation bei allem was produktivität
erhöht und ich muss ihnen aber auch
sagen an der stelle mehr nur debatten
führt tank gegen teller der gefährdet
nachhaltigkeitsziele wer gefährdet die
kreislaufwirtschaft und eher erschwert
fruchtfolgen und er erweist damit den
herausforderungen der zukunft doch einen
bärendienst und um die stabilität
europas zu sichern
müssen wir hier im deutschen bundestag
uns mit der frage der produktivität von
landwirtschaft ganz neu beschäftigen
davon bin ich fest überzeugt und wir
sind technologiestandort deutschland wir
sind industriestandort deutschland und
ich persönlich und auch meine fraktion
wir sind davon überzeugt dass genau die
stärke ist die uns auch helfen kann auf
diesen krisen herauszukommen modernen
büro- und züchtung technologien sind
auch freiheits technologien um mal im
bild dieser koalition zu leiden denn sie
unabhängiger die massen uns unabhängiger
von pflanzenschutz sie machen uns
unabhängiger von düngemitteln und das
ist die herausforderung die wir jetzt
bewältigen müssen das ist der
paradigmenwechsel der wir brauchen wir
müssen unabhängiger werden von dünge
importen aus russland
wie macht man das denn dünne produktion
dass energieintensive die energie die
uns ein zur verfügung steht ist die
sonne die sonne als photosynthese viel
mehr zu nutzen um pflanzen zu züchten
und mit neuen züchtungsmethoden auch
schneller neue worten in der fläche zu
haben die meinetwegen auch
luftstickstoff synthetisieren können
versuche dazu gibt es die knöllchen
bakterien algen bakterien auch an die
pflanzen zwischen um luftstickstoff in
energie in wachstum in nahrungsmittel
und auch in energie für treibstoff
umzuwandeln das ist teil der lösung und
davon sind bin ich fest überzeugt und
deshalb nutze ich diese aktuelle stunde
auch dafür zu werben dass
paradigmenwechsel eingeleitet werden
müssen aus krisen heraus und damit sind
wir nicht alleine damit bin ich nicht
alleine die ip sie hat das gesagt
studien die auch gerade die
zielerreichung der farm to fork ziele
die uns die europäische union im rahmen
des green deal vorgibt sagen dass
biotechnologie in der landwirtschaft ist
ein punkt den wir nicht vergessen dürfen
bei der neue betrachtung unserer ziele
und ich sage ihnen aber auch ganz gerne
scheins wir müssen aufhören mit diesem
entweder oder mit diesem sowohl-als-auch
wir brauchen alles wir brauchen
nachhaltigkeit und produktivität wir
brauchen weniger ideologie und mehr
technologie die zukunft der
landwirtschaft die ist ökologisch und
produktiv davon bin ich fest überzeugt
und ihnen dankbar dafür dass sie trotz
den verfehlungen und trotzdem falschen
ausrichtung der agrarpolitik in den
letzten jahren hier diese debatte heute
anstoßen damit wir darüber reden können
wie wir die herausforderungen der
zukunft besser bewältigen als wir das in
der vergangenheit getan haben vielen
dank
carina konrad hat hier auch auf
alternative
produktionsmöglichkeiten
hingewiesen und sven schultze wird als
nächstes sprechen minister für
wirtschaft tourismus landwirtschaft
des landes
nordrhein-westfalen
[Applaus]
hatte frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
damen und herren
abgeordnete ich bin sehr dankbar dass
ich hier heute reden darf ich bin
aktuell auch der vorsitzende der
agrarministerkonferenz
hier in deutschland und wir hatten vor
einigen tagen hatte mir sie erinnern
sich sie waren die ganze zeit mit dabei
agrarministerkonferenz
durchgeführt wir haben genau über dieses
thema was wir heute diskutieren sehr
intensiv diskutiert viele stunden
miteinander diskutiert und ich möchte
die gelegenheit nutzen
zu erklären wie wir das dort diskutiert
haben die agrarminister der länder
und warum wir das diskutiert haben wir
haben das thema nutzung von
vorrangflächen nicht deshalb diskutiert
weil hier aus dem bundestag oder aus
irgendeinem landesparlament die idee kam
die idee kam aus brüssel von der
europäischen kommission
und ich habe die letzten sieben jahre
als abgeordnete des europäischen
parlaments die kommission auch die
aktuelle geführt von ursula von der
leyen sehr gut kennengelernt ich glaube
diese kommission ist die kommission die
am meisten im bereich umweltschutz
artenschutz nachhaltigkeit vor ort
stichwort green dir das megaprojekt
dieser kommission wenn diese kommission
nicht sagt liebe mitgliedstaaten wir
haben ein massives problem nicht in
euren mitgliedstaaten nicht bei uns in
deutschland ich glaube bei uns in
deutschland wird keine
nahrungsmittelknappheit geben aber in
afrika dort wo die ärmsten der armen
leben dort wird es möglicherweise sehr
wahrscheinlich jetzt sogar eine
knappheit geben und wir müssen einen
beitrag leisten als deutschland und als
europäische union wenn diese kommission
das sagt dann muss man das glaube ich
sehr ernst nehmen
und wir haben dieses thema sehr intensiv
diskutiert weil die agrarminister sehr
unterschiedlicher parteien familien
entstanden
und ich kann ihnen sagen am ende des
tages kann man beschluss und wir haben
der bundesregierung empfohlen das war ja
damals noch nicht so weit dass sie das
schließen konnten beziehungsweise
entscheiden konnten dann hören sie mal
ruhig zu wir haben wir haben empfohlen
dass man das was aus brüssel kommt eins
zu eins umsetzen sollen wir haben eines
gesagt dass es nicht
das ist nicht eine infragestellung der
gemeinsamen europäischen agrarpolitik
hat niemand gesagt kein verband
gefordert keinen minister gefordert wir
haben gesagt in dieser schlimmen
situation müssen wir einen beitrag
leisten und was hat man auch nicht
gesagt niemand hat behauptet dass damit
die lösung da ist für alle probleme aber
es ist ein kleiner bestandteil vieler
bausteine die wir brauchen um hier
lösungen zu finden und vielleicht mal
zum abstimmungsergebnis
wir haben darüber abgestimmt wir haben
keine einheitlichkeit gefunden das haben
die agrarminister von cdu/csu von spd
von fdp- und von linkspartei sich dafür
ausgesprochen brüssel eins zu eins
umzusetzen und dagegen fahren besprochen
die agrarminister aus hamburg bremen
berlin schleswig holstein brandenburg
und sachsen sie wissen dass es alles im
bereich wo den verantwortung der grünen
partei und ich sage ihnen ganz ehrlich
das hat uns schon sehr geschockt aber
das ist ein ergebnis was wir akzeptieren
mussten genauso übrigens wie das
ergebnis im bundesrat dort wurde er auch
entsprechend darüber abgestimmt über
diskutiert im bauausschuss etwas anders
als im umweltausschuss
fakt ist fakt ist wir müssen handeln und
ich fand das eben ganz spannend ich habe
ja schon zugehört bei der befragung der
bundesregierung als die parlamentarische
staatssekretärin gesagt hat agrarflächen
sind begrenzt und sollten zur
nahrungsmittelversorgung dienen das ist
doch genau das thema und genau das
wollen wir
und schauen wir natürlich weil ich ein
absolut überzeugte europäer wenn
angeschaut was haben denn die anderen
staaten gemacht die da betroffen sind
beispielsweise österreich wo die grünen
mitregieren die betroffenen staaten
haben das alle entsprechend umgesetzt
wer hat versagt da bände deutschland hat
versagt ich glaube vielleicht man muss
es konkretisieren der letzte mehr da
haben sie versagt an dieser stelle da
hätten sie an der terminus ist
vornehme ja zuweilen auch die zahlen die
da genannt werden wird man sagt das
hilft doch alles nichts 0,8 millionen
tonnen
ins verhältnis gesetzt 800.000 tonnen
sind das wenn man sich mal so ein 40
tonner getreide vorstellt dass die hat
ja nicht 40 stunden drauf der hat 25 26
stunden drauf dann sind das 30.000 l gab
es allein in diesem jahr die wir gehabt
hätten 30.000 lkws da kann man doch
nicht sagen dass es nichts
auch wenn es mir
weißt ich es mir erlaubt es aber ich
habe es zumindest auch zur kenntnis
genommen
es gab ja eine anfrage der abgeordneten
heike brehmer hier an die
bundesregierung wie man denn nun mit
dieser thematik umgeht und die antwort
kennen viele von ihnen man hat
geantwortet wir haben eine frist gab die
ist abgelaufen deshalb wird man in
diesem jahr nichts machen also wenn man
so miteinander umgeht schwierig und das
ist die vergangenheit jetzt geben über
die zukunft jetzt reden wir über 2023
und jetzt sage ich immer was mir viele
bohren sagen die bauern sagen lieber
herr schulze sie sind vorsitzender
agrarministerkonferenz bitte helfen sie
mit dazu beizutragen zum einen dass wir
auch einen beitrag leisten können als
bauern zum zweiten dass wir nicht in die
ecke gestellt werden dass wir ja alles
aufheben wollen wir wollen eine für ein
jahr zwei 22 und 42 23 für das zweite
jahr wir wollen helfen wir wollen da was
machen wir brauchen aber jetzt auch eine
klare ansage zum einen aus der
europäischen union und da ist die
bundesregierung gefordert auch mit der
eu entsprechend zu reden und zu
verhandeln was wir 2023 machen weil die
bauern müssen wissen ob sie nach dieser
ernte jetzt den boden bearbeiten können
oder nicht und zum anderen wir erwarten
auch ärzte mir bitte eine klare aussage
wie sie sich für das jahr 2023 verhalten
werden für den fall dass die eu auch im
jahr 2023 die vier prozent zur verfügung
stellt da brauchen wir jetzt schnell
auch eine klare aussage ich sage ihnen
das auch die agrarministerkonferenz ist
jederzeit bereit mit ihnen in diesem
format kurzfristig auch ins gespräch zu
kommen ich biete ihnen das eine
es ist für uns alle die an der politik
tätig sind überhaupt kein problem wenn
wir stundenlang nächte lang verhandeln
wir können uns streiten wir können
diskutieren aber wir haben zwei ebenen
die jetzt schnelle lösungen brauchen das
eine sind unsere bauern in deutschland
die brauchen jetzt eine aussage und das
zweite das sind die menschen auf dieser
welt speziell in afrika was wird denn
passieren wie europäer wir können es uns
leisten ende des jahres wenn das
getreide knapp wird dann können wir uns
das leisten dass auch zu kaufen das ist
so da müssen sie sich auch mit
auseinandersetzen das können wir uns
leisten die afrikaner werden sich das
nicht leisten können und dann ist die
frage wer das zu verantworten hat ich
möchte es nicht verantworten ich möchte
es nicht verantworten und deshalb haben
wir entsprechende vorschläge gemacht und
erhitzte mio wir treffen uns im herbst
wir treffen uns im herbst in sachsen
anhalt sachsen anhalt hat die besten
böden deutschlands unterböden dort kommt
die bodenwerte zahl her für diejenigen
die es interessiert wir gehen nach
quedlinburg und es wäre doch eine tolle
sache letzte mir wenn sie mit der
bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
entsprechenden kolleginnen und kollegen
hier aus dem deutschen bundestag und mit
der agrarministerkonferenz eine
vernünftige lösung suchen in dieser
konfliktlage der letzten monate hat das
doch dieses haus gezeigt dass man
parteiübergreifend bei anderen themen
auch vernünftige lösung gesucht und
gefunden hat wir bieten ihnen das an als
agrarminister ich bitte sie darum
wirklich dieses thema entsprechend als
zu nehmen und das was jetzt gestern
abend vorgeschlagen haben das ist ein
erster kleiner baustein das ist aber
noch lange nicht alles was wir brauchen
vielen dank
sven schultze war das der wir selber
gesagt hat aus dem bundesland in den
besten böden kommt und zwar aus sachsen
anhalt nicht aus nordrhein westfalen
auf ihn folgt nun wieder eine
abgeordnete des deutschen bundestags das
ist peggy schierenbeck aus der
spd-fraktion und sie ist mitglied im
ausschuss für ernährung und
landwirtschaft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister sehr geehrte
damen und herren
der apfel frei die gurke zu kommen und
die tomate zu planen es muss nicht immer
perfekt sein und es muss auch nicht in
die tonne unser ziel ist ganz klar wir
müssen hunger weltweit und aktuell auf
in der ukraine vermeiden dazu gehört
darüber nachzudenken welchen beitrag wir
leisten können wir dürfen uns nicht aus
unserer verantwortung ziehen deshalb
sollten wir jetzt noch viel intensiver
als bisher die lebensmittelverschwendung
in den blick nehmen denn das gesamte
lebensmittelangebot stets zu günstigsten
preisen zur verfügung steht ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit
das dürfte jetzt allen klar sein wir
brauchen mehr wertschätzung für
lebensmittel einen achtsamen umgang mit
ihnen zugleich müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass ernährung kein luxusgut wird so
können wir effektiv zur
ernährungssicherheit beitrag wussten sie
dass in deutschland rund 12 millionen
tonnen lebensmittel abfälle im jahr
entstehen
dann vor davon wäre die hälfte
grundsätzlich vermeidbar dieser zustand
ist nicht vertretbar wir wollen
lebensmittelverschwendung auf allen
ebenen bekämpfen das heißt vom acker bis
zum teller
denn viele der produzierten lebensmittel
schaffen es gar nicht in den handel
die gründe sind vielfältig falsche
erntezeit wir haben gerade gehört sie
verbrennen auf den feldern
schlechte lagerung schlechter transport
oder auch weil sie dann noch nicht
entsprechen zu krümmen zu reif oder zu
klein sind
lebensmittel die die nie in unseren
landen verursachen einen unnötigen
verbrauch von ressourcen wie landflächen
wasser energie und dünger dabei stoßen
wir viele vermeidbare emissionen aus der
kampf gegen lebensmittelverschwendung
hilft also auch gegen den klimawandel
auch ethisch ist
lebensmittelverschwendung angesichts
weltweit mehr als 800 millionen
hungernder menschen nicht akzeptabel
genau hier wollen wir ansetzen und diese
enorme verschwendung einen riegel
vorschieben
es geht es geht vor allem darum
lebensmittelabfälle entlang der gesamten
versorgungskette zu vermeiden denn hier
besteht ein enormes
einsparungspotenzial an lebensmitteln
die woanders dringend gebraucht werden
es gibt bereits viele ansätze wie
lebensmittel genutzt und verteilt werden
können die tafeln leisten hier eine
wertvolle arbeit stoßen aber auch an
ihre grenzen durch die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise gibt es immer mehr
bedürftige und auf der anderen seite
bekommen die tafel immer weniger
lebensmittelspenden
außerdem wollen wir die wertschätzung
für lebensmittel insgesamt stärken auch
das ist an die gesamtgesellschaftliche
aufgabe bei der jeder und jeder gefragt
ist sehr groß und 1 genauso wie die
gastronomie und private haushalte geben
wir doch bei unserem kühlschrank
wir alle sehen dass die aktuelle
entwicklung auch zu steigenden
lebensmittelpreisen führt bei alldem
sollten wir im blick haben lebensmittel
dürften nicht so teuer werden dass sie
sich niemand mehr leisten kann essen
darf kein luxusgut werden vor allem im
hinblick auf gesunde und nachhaltige
ernährung
unsere bundesminister für inneres
landwirtschaft ihrem ex premier hat sich
dafür ausgesprochen gesunden und
nahrungsmittel wie obst und gemüse und
hülsenfrüchte von der mehrwertsteuer zu
befreien damit unterstützt der forderung
von mediziner in eine soziale und
verbraucherverbänden wichtig ist mir vor
allem eine gesunde ernährung darf keine
frage des geldbeutels sein mit unserer
umfassenden in ihrem strategie wollen
wir sicherstellen dass an die gesunde
ernährung für alle möglich ist wir
müssen bei den jetzigen
herausforderungen trotzdem die weichen
für die ernährung der zukunft stellen
dazu müssen wir eine unter anderem
pflanzen basierte ernährungs stärker
fördern derzeit wird in deutschland über
die hälfte der agrarflächen für den
anbau von tierfutter verwendet
langfristig müssen wir ressourcen
einsparen langfristig ihre bestände
reduzieren und pflanzliche alternativen
stärken die aktuelle krisen zeigen
gerade jetzt wissen wir
gerade jetzt müssen wir unser
nahrungsmittel system und unsere
ernährung in den fokus rücken für uns
ist klar wir müssen gesunde ernährung
fördern lebensmittel verschwendung
vermeiden und hunger bekämpfen dafür
brauchen wir eine ernährungs wende jetzt
[Applaus]
einen schönen guten tag von wanda seite
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen und wir
führen in der aktuellen stunde fort und
der nächste redner ist dr jan niklas
gesenhues bündnis 90 die grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe unionsfraktion ehrlich
gesagt habe ich auf den antrag auf diese
aktuelle stunde schon gewartet weil ich
mir schon gedacht habe dass sie der
versuchung nicht widerstehen können
diese populistische forderungen hier ins
plenum zu tragen ja und und der zweite
grund der zweite grund weswegen ich
eigentlich schon drauf gewartet habe
dass sie hier diesen tagesordnungspunkt
setzen ist weil es mir mal die
gelegenheit gibt ihnen aufzuzeigen ihre
rechnung geht schlicht und einfach nicht
auf weil sie letztendlich eine maßnahme
vorschlagen ohne wirklich signifikante
wirkung für globale ernährungssicherheit
der sagt ihnen übrigens auch das
welternährungsprogramm
weil wir eben es angesprochen haben es
angesprochen worden in erster linie ein
verteilungsproblem haben und sie
schlagen diese maßnahme vor ohne echte
wirkung unter inkaufnahme starker
naturzerstörung meine damen und herren
deswegen ist das auch schlicht und
einfach untauglich was sie ihr vorschlag
und ich will auch mal in aller
deutlichkeit sagen wenn sie in dieser
lage diese ernährungskrise
instrumentalisieren um den schutz von
natur und umwelt zurück zu drehen dann
werden sie auf dauer beides verlieren
das ist ein gefährliches handeln hier
machen weil sie damit auf dauer
ernährungssicherheit und die intakte
natur verlor verlieren werden dass es
keine seriöse politik denn das hängt
ganz eng miteinander zusammen es sind
doch die intakte ökosysteme die unsere
böden frucht behalten die das wasser
sauber halten und verfügbar halten und
die die bestäubung sicherstellen und
diese ökosystemleistungen die können sie
auch technisch nicht ersetzen ich will
das noch mal wiederholen diese
wertvollen ökosystemleistungen die sind
technisch nicht ersetzbar und deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass wir klima und
biodiversität schützen
wir
stärken deswegen dem klima und
artenschutz weil das eben auch
ernährungs relevant ist und weil das
auch
sicherheitsrelevant ist denn schon heute
sehen wir ja die folgen dieser
kurzsichtigen landwirtschaftspolitik der
letzten jahre millionen menschen sind
durch die ökologische krise und hunger
ganz konkret bedroht wir haben
hunderttausende klimaflüchtlinge
kollabierende ökosysteme und in dieser
situation geben wir 60 prozent der ernte
in die fleischerzeugung das ist doch
absurd meine damen und herren das kann
doch nicht angehen dazu kommt das was in
den tank geht und ihre cdu reden heute
stehen in der tradition dieser fatalen
und global ungerechten
landwirtschaftspolitik meine damen und
herren
und was wir stattdessen jetzt leuchten
statt solcher ideologischer symbol
anträge was wir jetzt wirklich brauchen
ist akute nothilfe das hat der minister
vorhin angedeutet in dem wir auch mehr
fläche für die futtermittel erzeugung
beispielsweise freigeben aber vor allem
in dem wir auch mehr mittel
bereitstellen für die welternährung
jetzt ganz konkret zum beispiel auch
noch mal über den ergänzungs haushalt
und
und indem wir dieses problem nicht nur
kurzfristig angehen sondern vor allem
ernährungssouveränität auch auf dauer
absichern und da spielt zum beispiel die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit eine ganz
wichtige rolle wir brauchen eine starke
eine wirkungsvolle
entwicklungszusammenarbeit um die
wertschöpfung vor ort zu stärken und es
war ganz viel über afrika insgesamt die
rede das kann man da auch nicht
verallgemeinern das ist sehr
differenziert aber was ganz ganz wichtig
ist dass wir die ernährungssouveränität
weltweit stärken und das spielt
entwicklungszusammenarbeit eine ganz
ganz starke rolle
und in denen wir den globalen schutz der
lebensgrundlagen sicherstellen dass ist
auch ernährungs und sicherheitsrelevante
ich hab's angesprochen aber damit müssen
wir dann auch hier konkret bei uns
anfangen und genau das ist das was der
landwirtschaftsminister hier auch
vorgeschlagen hat und
und lassen sie nicht abschließend noch
mal eine ganz grundsätzliche anmerkungen
machen
wir sind nach wie vor in dieser
situation die ukraine wird angegriffen
übrigens auch gerade die bäuerinnen und
bauern in der ukraine die sind auch
gezielt angriffen ausgesetzt und dass
sie trotzdem in dieser situation alles
tun um nahrungsmittel anzubauen und auch
zu versuchen diese zu exportieren dafür
gebührt ihnen unser größter respekt und
dank meine damen und herren
und in so einer situation ist solch ein
antrag schlicht und einfach unangemessen
und ich will wirklich mal an sie
appellieren überlegen sie wirklich nicht
nochmal ob nicht auch zeitenwende
bedeutet mal alte glaubenssätze in frage
zu stellen
und es wäre ein
es wäre ein anfang wenn sie ihre
nachgewiesenermaßen schädlichen
glaubenssätze in der
landwirtschaftspolitik in frage stellen
würde ich nur tun sie es nicht für mich
tun sie es im interesse von mehr
globaler gerechtigkeit vielen dank
ihren niklas gesenhues aus der
linksfraktion hat hier
doch die politik sein des ministers
verteidigt von tim zu mir und auf ihn
folgt nun georg lehmann zocker der
landwirtschaftspolitische sprecher der
fdp fraktion im deutschen bundestag
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
ich nehme wahr dass die
landwirtschaftlichen und
wirtschaftspolitischen debatten in
dieser legislaturperiode mit einem
anderen zungenschlag geführt werden als
das in der letzten legislaturperiode der
fall gewesen ist
ich werde mich als ehemaliger
oppositionsabgeordneter sehr gut daran
dass wir die damalige bundesregierung
immer wieder ermahnen mussten doch keine
nationalen alleingänge zu beschreiten
und dass wir immer wieder darum gekämpft
haben nicht immer erfolgreich die
zurückzuholen sozusagen auf die
grundlage von wissenschaftlichkeit und
fachlichkeit verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen unter fällt es schon auf dass
die diskussion in dieser
legislaturperiode sehr viel mehr geprägt
sind von wertschätzung für
landwirtschaft für
lebensmittelproduktion
sehr viel mehr geprägt sind von
diskussionen darüber welchen preis ein
landwirt eigentlich bekommen muss am
markt um seine kosten decken zu können
und viele andere dinge mehr und
natürlich ist dieser neue zungenschlag
auch begründet durch den fürchterlichen
krieg in der ukraine
aber ich sage ihnen ganz ausdrücklich
ein grund dafür ist auch der umstand
dass diese bundesregierung von drei
partnern getragen wird muss von
mindestens einer immer dann den finger
mahnend erhebt wenn die gefahr besteht
dass man sich auf nationale alleingänge
macht und die fehler der letzten die 16
jahre wiederholt und wortstark werde
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen wiederhole ich auch hier im
deutschen bundestag das noch mal sehr
gerne was ich an anderer stelle immer
wieder in den letzten tagen und wochen
gesagt habe meine sehr verdammen und
herren ist erscheint mir in zeiten wo in
europa ein krieg herrscht
in zeiten wo in europa einen krieg
herrscht wo relevante volumina an den
weltmärkten wegbrechen erscheint es mir
ehrlicherweise völlig aus der zeit
gefallen wenn man an dem was die letzte
bundesregierung seinerzeit mal
verhandelt hat einfach festhalten wollte
und diese vereinbarung von früher nicht
noch mal auf den prüfstand stellt und
nicht noch einmal hinterfragt und
deswegen sage ich ihnen ganz
ausdrücklich ich glaube natürlich müssen
wir neu denken und natürlich dürfen wir
nicht landwirtschaftliche flächen von
vier prozent tatsächlich still liegt
aber und das sage ich ihnen aber ganz
ausdrücklich dass kunden sie seinerzeit
noch nicht wissen als das konnten sie
seinerzeit noch nicht wissen als sie das
mit verhandelt haben ehrlicherweise ist
es mir auch schwer wie man in
friedenszeiten überhaupt eine solche
absicht formulieren kann denn meine
damen und herren wir kämpfen gegen den
klimawandel wir sehen wie viel flächen
uns für landwirtschaftliche nutzung
verloren gingen durch verwüstung und
durch versteppung wir wissen dass die
tatsächlich die bevölkerungszahlen immer
größer werden die versiegelten flächen
und damals sehr viel nahmen dann ist es
auch in friedens- und nicht nur in
kriegszeiten falsch krampfhaft flächen
aus der produktion zu nehmen und es
würde mich interessieren lieber kollege
stegemann wie du sie sieht das
vielleicht erklären können wenn du
gleich deine regeln nochmal hält wie man
überhaupt damals schon noch diese idee
hat kommen können was im krieg absurd
anmutet ist in friedenszeiten nicht mehr
ausdrücklich richtig gewesen verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
und deswegen
will ich das an dieser stelle ganz
ausdrücklich an die kolleginnen und
kollegen der union richten diese
aktuelle stunde eingebracht haben sie
bemühen mit ihrem erbe der vier prozent
ein narrativ dass sie eigentlich bei
anderen zu recht regelmäßig kritisieren
nämlich das narrativ dass die
landwirtschaftliche nutzung von flächen
sozusagen im konflikt stunde zu
nachhaltigkeit und zu biodiversität und
ich sage ihnen ganz ausdrücklich diese
erzählung die gehörte irgendwo ins
letzte jahrtausend aber nicht mehr ins
jahr 2002 und ich sage ihnen ganz
ausdrücklich mit modernster technologie
sind wir gerade in der lage eine
symbiose von ökonomie und ökologie
gerade in der landwirtschaft hin zu
bekommen ich lade sie gerne mal ein nach
niedersachsen machen sie sich mal ein
bild davon wie intensiv und
biodiversität das jetzt gerade blüht für
insekten eine wunderbare lebensgrundlage
ist eine nahrungsgrundlage da steht für
vögel eine nahrungsgrundlage darstellt
aber das narrativ weiterhin zu bemühen
zu glauben dass es zwei verschiedene
pole sozusagen während man sich für
einen entscheiden müsste das ist
komplett falsch es ist allerhöchste zeit
dass sie von der union anerkennen dass
ökologie und ökonomie in der
landwirtschaft zwei seiten zwei seiten
derselben medaille sind und keine
gegensätze herzlichen dank
ihrer clemens hocker war das hier für
die fdp-fraktion hatte ich mal ein paar
kreis eingeladen
auf ihn folgt nun albert stegemann er
ist der sprecher für ernährung und
landwirtschaft der unionsfraktion sehr
geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen liebe kollegen ja vor
wenigen tagen titelten die blätter
agrarminister özdemir einer der
beliebtesten politiker erstmal
herzlichen glückwunsch doch wie kommt
man zu dieser ehre immer schön im
allgemeinen bleiben nichts
konkretisieren immer schön verständnis
für die landwirte äußern aber auch hier
ja nicht konkret werden und bei einer
ernährungs und versorgungskrise in
europa und deutschland ebenfalls
fehlanzeige solcher minister ihre
beliebtheit stellen kein zeugnis für
ihre handlungsfähigkeit da sie sind und
bleiben ankündigungsminister
nun aber ganz konkret zum thema wir
reden hier heute über die vier prozent
flächenstilllegung die ab dem nächsten
jahr geplant sind wir als union fordern
hier ganz klar diese stilllegung
auszusetzen sie als ampel wollen jedoch
auf diese nachhaltige wirkung dieser
maßnahme nicht verzichten das ist der
politische spannungsbogen die idee 4
prozent der fläche aus der
landwirtschaftlichen produktion zu
nehmen stammt aus einer zeit einer guten
versorgungslage durch den schrecklichen
angriff putins auf die ukraine hat sich
die lage jedoch völlig verändert wir
brauchen diese flächen dringend um die
lebensmittelversorgung in europa und
deutschland zu sichern
nun argumentieren sie dass sie eine
krise nicht gegen die andere krise
ausspielen wollen okay aber wie
tragfähig ist denn überhaupt diese
argumentation sie sprechen hier immer
wieder vom klimaschutz und sie sprechen
auch immer wieder die artenvielfalt an
daran ist uns als union im übrigen
genauso gelegen das will ich einmal hier
vorwärts schieben aber was für eine
jetzt gehen wir doch mal gehen wir
schauen wir uns sind die sache mal
konkret was für eine klimarelevante
bedeutung hat denn die schwarz brachte
es geht um die schwache sie wollen
flächen brachliegen lassen worauf kommt
es aber an beim klimaschutz kaum aufrufs
und das ist bei der schwarzbacher der
fall bedeutet auch kaum co2 bindung denn
wo keine pflanzen da kann auch kein co2
gebunden werden also
kommen sie ziehen sie komplett am ziel
vorbei übrigen gilt dasselbe auch für
die insekten und auch für das thema
artenvielfalt wo sie keine pflanzen
haben sie eben auch keine insekten also
bei licht betrachtet ist auch dass hier
ein trugschluss also für insekten ist
eine unbewirtschaftete fläche in etwa
genauso langweilig wie ein kaleidoskop
für einen blinden also von daher lieber
ampel
sie erreichen durch dieses fragwürdige
maßnahme der stilllegung doch überhaupt
nicht ihr ziel stattdessen wieder
nebelkerzen und herr minister dabei
finden der tag doch so gut an heute
morgen die erste ticker meldung die ich
wahrgenommen habe özdemir will mehr
weizenanbau ermöglichen eu-regelung
verschieben und ich habe gedacht ja wohl
endlich er hat es verstanden aber war es
mal wieder eins überschrift erzeugt aber
nichts erreicht ist es eigentlich
wirklich ihr ernst dass das aufheben der
fruchtfolge regelung in der glotze 7
regelung tatsächlich etwas bringt selbst
wenn sie jetzt etwas mehr weizen
produzieren aber diese fläche steht dann
doch anderen pflanzen und anderen
produktionsrichtungen überhaupt nicht
mehr zur verfügung das ist eine
nebelkerze das ist ihr wirklich
schaufensterpolitik und das ist typisch
ritzte mir also das können wir ihnen
einfach an dieser stelle nicht
durchgehen lassen so und dann komme ich
auch noch mal zu ihnen frau künast sie
können es ja auch nicht lassen immer
wieder zu betonen dass er die vier
prozent im grunde genommen gar keinen
beitrag leisten würden und könnten um
dieser krise etwas zu entgegnen
ich sage ihnen wir haben in deutschland
elf millionen hektar ackerland wenn sie
davon 4 prozent nehmen dann reden wir
jemanden über 440.000 hektar wenn sie
auf diesen 440.000 hektar
50 50 tonnen kartoffeln ehren was sich
ungewöhnlich ist dann reden wir hier
über 22 millionen tonnen nahrungsmittel
also bitte
bitte wären sie sich diesen realitäten
an und erkennen sie haben dass es ein
relevanter weiter dazu ist um dieser
krise etwas entgegenzusetzen
übrigens kriege ich es auch nicht
zusammenhält sie mir was ihr in
haushaltspolitischen debatten immer
wieder tun regional ist es verständlich
dass sie sich eben auf die schwäbische
hausfrau hier konzentrieren aber die kam
natürlich nicht auf die idee wenn das
portemonnaie leer ist dann trotzdem
nochmals vier euro auszugeben weil es
dann ja nicht mal darauf ankommt also
von daher glaube ich ist es auch nochmal
sinnvoll da sie sich der untereinander
also in jetziger situation fällt jeder
hektar und wie gesagt deswegen
appelliere ich noch einmal werden sie
aktiv sie haben bisher wirklich leider
nichts auf den weg gebracht sie sind
fast ein halbes jahr im amt kein gesetz
keine verordnung sie haben zwar viel
verständnis und haben immer schöne reden
aber am ende kommt nie was konkretes
dabei rum wir sind in einer ernsten
situation nehmen sie ihre verantwortung
wahr und dann unterstützen wir sie auch
dabei vielen dank
albert stegemann war das hier auch mit
deutlicher kritik an
bundeswirtschaftsminister cem özdemir
und damit kommen wir zur vorletzten
rednerin in dieser aktuellen stunde das
ist susanne mittag die sprichwort für
ernährung und landwirtschaft der
sozialdemokraten hier im deutschen
parlament
und kollegen das hört sich ja richtig
gut so logisch die überschrift und so
empathisch und welchen hunger meinen sie
eigentlich ja wohl nicht den hier in
deutschland und europa denn die
versorgung ist absehbar gesichert das
würde sogar heute im ausschuss deutlich
sondern da wo er am härtesten ist und
das ist in somalia im jemen im tschad im
kongo in liberia um nur einige der am
stärksten betroffenen länder aufzuzählen
da geht es aber nicht darum hoher zu
vermeiden sondern der ist das schon
einige jahre und die welthungerhilfe
musste im letzten jahr schon die ration
halbieren will einige mitgliedsländer
nicht gezahlt haben
und jetzt mal ganz schön die nerven
bewahren es geht gleich weiter und in
den letzten jahren waren die bemühungen
der cdu im cdu geführten
landwirtschaftsministerium übersichtlich
den hunger der auch durch
klimaveränderungen massiv betroffenen
länder besonders in den sub sahara
staaten durch entwicklungen im bereich
der eigenen landwirtschaft vor ort zu
bekämpfen ich kann mich nicht an einen
derartigen antrag erinnern
das wird umgehen das wird umgehend
unsere aufgabe die möglichkeit der
eigenversorgung und wieder einfach mal
zu sieht es noch ganz geschafft bis
jetzt seien die möglichkeiten der
eigenversorgung mittel und langfristig
zu sichern und daher ist dieser von der
union beantragten aktuellen stunde wurde
er der zu erwartende hunger gemeint nach
angaben des ukrainischen
agrarministers liegen in der ukraine 20
millionen tonnen weizen für den export
auf lager 20 millionen nutzern
vergleicht die von ihnen geforderte zu
schlecken zusätzliche
flächenbewirtschaftung
ergeben allenfalls schon erwähnt 0,8 tom
wenn es gut läuft wenn wir ein
ordentlich zimmer haben trotz des
krieges werden 75 prozent der
ackerfläche bestellt ist natürlich die
frage nach was rauskommt aber die
gleiche frage können wir uns in
deutschland stellen hier liegt also ganz
klar ein transportproblem vor durch
verminte häfen defekte gleise und
fehlende lademöglichkeiten und dazu
besteht ein enger austausch zwischen
deutschen kritischen ministern zwischen
landwirtschaftsministern auch hier
verkehrsministerium um das zu regeln
damit die lager geleert werden können
für die nächste ernte die ja schon an
steht ein europäischer
aktionsplan wird gerade erstellt der es
nächste woche im ausschuss und die
g7-minister konferenz tagt am wochenende
wie erwähnt worden ist es nicht so dass
nichts passiert nummer zum vorredner bei
weizen wird genauso auf kriesel not und
einen eventuellen angel spekuliert wie
bei dünger sonnenblume benzin und diesel
auch um nur einige zu nennen
angesichts niedriger zinsen haben
spekulanten seit einigen jahren agrar
rohstoff fonds für sich entdeckt und die
preisspirale nach oben gedreht es macht
es halt attraktiver überschüssige
getreidemengen zurückzuhalten anstatt
sie auf den markt zu bringen und mit
krieg aus
seit 2008 zehn steigen
seit 2008 zehn steigen kontinuierlich
die anbau mengen für weizen weltweit und
das wird auch für 2022 erwartet über 220
millionen tonnen die dünger industrie im
getreidehandel melden weltweit
rekordgewinne jetzt das problem sind die
hohen preise und nicht der mangel und
darum ist die unterstützung globaler
ernährungsprogrammen kurzfristig wichtig
ist schon gesagt wurden 430 millionen
steuert deutschland dazu bei den
brachflächen die schon im ausschuss in
der öffentlichkeit und hier von der
cdu/csu als unbedingt zu bewirtschaften
deklariert werden frage ich nicht
manchmal so ein bisschen ob sie ihr
folgendes bedacht haben dass diese
flächen nicht gerade hochwertig sind das
haben wir ja schon mal gehört dass die
flächen natürlich auch gedüngt werden
müssen dünger und diesel sind ja
ebenfalls preislich gestiegen das seit
wochen nicht geregnet hat in der
landwirtschaft jetzt schon grundsätzlich
eine wasserproblematik besteht und wir
nicht wissen was uns unser sommer
diesmal thematisch beschert und ein
weiterer aspekt ist vielleicht sollte
man den mal bedenken das
vertragsverletzungsverfahren
hinsichtlich der ausweisung rote gebiete
hat auch was mit dünger zu tun wir
brauchen bis zum sommer eine
einvernehmliche regelung mit der eu und
es ist noch nicht klar ob und welche
auswirkungen die ausweitung der
geduldeten anbauflächen unter umständen
da hat das ist um zufälligerweise noch
gar nicht erwähnt worden und schließlich
einen nicht ganz unwesentlicher punkt
wir haben die verdienen kritisierten
maßnahmen überhaupt nicht beschlossen
der von ihnen kritisierte regelung zu
brachflächen ökologische vorrangflächen
wir haben die agrarminister der länder
zugestimmt auch wenn es offensichtlich
schwierig war zugestimmt ist zugestimmt
und die ganze wurde von ihrer früheren
landwirtschaftsministerin entworfen und
ebenfalls im bundesrat beschlossen so
und da ist die cdu sogar mehrfach
vertreten
und das wissen sie und trotzdem stellen
sie immer wieder die anträge und die
wiederholen sich immer ja oder sie
willkommen zum schluss insofern ist es
nicht so dass
seitens der bundesregierung keine
maßnahmen getroffen werden die 180
millionen sind erwähnt worden
mittags
geregelt also insofern sind wir gar
nicht so schlecht unterwegs
und ich keine das wort firma
cdu/csu-fraktion
geschätzte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren in teilen
dieser reden habe ich fast den eindruck
viele haben noch nicht kapiert was am 24
februar passiert ist
es war es war ihr parteifreund und
bundeskanzler auch von einer zeitenwende
gesprungen hat eine zeitenwende die seit
24 februar stattfindet und wer hier die
alten sprechzettel aussieht das sind
auch die grünen das ist auch diese ampel
koalition und gerade wir haben doch die
verantwortung jetzt zu liefern jetzt
auch die bevölkerung mit nahrungsmitteln
zu versorgen seit 24
februar erleben wir angriffe auf die
infrastruktur
angriffe nicht nur barbarische
menschenrechtsverletzungen auf die
menschen leben auf angriffe auf die
infrastruktur der lebensmittelversorgung
helfen werden auch bombardiert
getreidelager getreidelager werden von
den bösen geplündert gestohlen minister
hat es selbst schon erwähnt
und wir reden jetzt auch nicht von der
aktuellen an wir reden von der
zukünftigen und nur zumal zur
information
auch im europäischen land kann man nur
einmal sehen nun einmal und wenn wir es
nicht schaffen für die zukünftige ernte
ausreichend nahrungsmittel zur verfügung
stellt dann stehen wir am vorabend einer
humanitären katastrophe
wenn afrika darauf angewiesen ist wenn
kenia zb 80 prozent seines weizen wortes
ausdruck rheine hat und da nicht mehr
bekommt dann stehen wir heute am
vorabend einer humanitären katastrophe
und deshalb gilt es zu handeln und
deshalb gilt es auch die notwendigen
maßnahmen zu ergreifen
ich bin dankbar denn dann war dass diese
bundesregierung und wir auch hier in
diesem parlament verantwortung
übernehmen ich denke an so manche
äußerungen
manche entscheidungen die eine annalena
baerbock oder europa gemacht sie haben
die zeitenwende registriert wir können
keine wir können nicht warten bis wir
panzer mit elektroantrieb ökostrom haben
wir müssen jetzt liefern aber in der
agrarpolitik müssen wir auch jetzt
liefern und der bereich der ökologischen
vorrangflächen da können wir jetzt noch
lange darüber streiten aber die
vegetation die schreite dahin die ende
kommt auf uns zu und die ist nicht
vorhanden wir wissen nicht was die
russen noch vorhaben ich sage nur eine
stichwort inbrandsetzung von weizen
fällt in der ukraine kurz vor der ernte
auch das steht vor der austritt auch das
müssen wir bedenken und wenn wir über
die zukünftige 4% stilllegung
diskutieren
dann heißt das auch dass wir das
kurzzeitig diskutieren müssen ist ja
nicht gottgegeben dass wir die nächsten
15 jahre auf diese stilllegung
verzichten wir müssen situationsabhängig
wir müssen in erster linie den hunger
auf der welt bekämpfen und dazu ist die
deutsche landwirtschaft bereit dazu sind
unsere bauernfamilien bereit das ist
eine ehre der bauern lebensmittel zu
produzieren und dazu müssen wir sie auch
unter
ich bin
bin auch dankbar das erste ansätze
kommen die ansatz mit der fruchtfolge
wobei da trifft auch wieder politische
ideologie und landwirtschaftliche
sachverstand aufeinander
wenn ich bei mir in der region wenn ich
bei mir in der region zweimal
hintereinander weizenanbau und hören sie
mal gut zu leben glücklich wenn ich bei
mir in der region zweimal hintereinander
weizenanbau dann brauche ich mindestens
eine fungizid behandlung also mehr
pflanzenschutzmittel wir wenig einiges
unter fruchtfolge ein heute wenig wenn
ich dagegen
wenn ich dagegen jahrelang auf der
gleichen fläche mais anbaue dann
funktioniert das ist landwirtschaftliche
praxis und da haben sie anscheinend noch
nicht die notwendige reife dazu und
ich wundere mich immer wieder
ich wundere mich immer wieder in diesen
deutschen bundestag wie sich die fdp so
verdrehen kann also in der letzten
legislaturperiode was haben wir hier für
schöne reden gehört von der gmf dpa
holger konto wie sie alle heißen was
haben sie für flammende reden gehalten
als rechter als kämpfer für die deutsche
landwirtschaft
die bauern in schleswig holstein hans
letzten sonntag schon kapiert und
nächsten sonntag wenn sie es auch in
nordrhein-westfalen
und
ich möchte sie auffordern
sind sehr hoch wenn sie
pressemitteilungen herausgehen wenn sie
whatsapp videos produzieren wenn sie
sonstige reden auch hier im deutschen
bundestag ein aber sie sind in
regierungsverantwortung sind in
regierungsrat deshalb blieben sie auch
lieben sie auch mit dieser an der
regierung dargestellt
und damit beenden wir die aktuelle
stunde
soweit also hier die aktuelle stunde das
thema wird wohl noch das eine oder
andere mal hier eine rolle spielen denn
auch die gemeinsame agrarpolitik der eu
ist ja ständig jetzt debatten thema 2023
soll nun die reform kommen in den die
umweltaspekte stärker in den fokus
genommen werden wenn es zahlungen für
landwirte und landwirtinnen gibt wir
schauen auf der nächste thema das hier
im plenarsaal diskutiert wird da geht es
um den bundes